bonjour merci d'être avec nous pour un
nouveau numéro de dimanche en politique
avec une question aujourd'hui qui seront
les candidats et les candidates à la
prochaine élection présidentielle c'est
dans moins de trois mois
une question à la fois simple et très
compliqué qui aurait même tendance à se
compliquer d'heure en heure pour en
débattre sur ce plateau qui rabroue
diane bonjour je vous êtes député
socialiste de côte-d'or on vous a classé
comme frondeuse vous souhaitiez soutenir
arnaud montebourg à la primaire avant de
vous ranger derrière benoît hamon
françois patriat bonjour bonjour vous
êtes sénateur socialiste de côte-d'or et
vous êtes aux côtés d' emmanuel macron
depuis le début dans maints pays depuis
deux ans fabienne cardo vous êtes nuls
les républicains en lanières bonjour
vous vous êtes vous aussi depuis le
début derrière françois fillon dont vous
êtes porte parole nationale pour la
société civile et alexandre emorine
bonjour bonjour vous représentez ici la
france a soumises de jean luc mélenchon
dont vous porter les couleurs en côte
d'or
rajoutons que le front national que nous
avions invité est excusé puisqu'il lance
à lyon pendant deux jours sa campagne un
débat diffusé simultanément sur facebook
où vous pouvez réagir et commenter je le
disais c'est à peu près du jamais vu
dans la vème république à une semaine du
premier tour de la présidentielle ce
sera le 23 avril le casting est encore
flou on pense forcément à la droite
d'abord fabienne cardo je le disais vous
êtes depuis le début derrière françois
fillon est ce qu'il peut de votre point
de vue raisonnablement être le candidat
de la droite
après ce qu'il traverse et ce qui peut
lui arriver dans les semaines qui
viennent
oui il peut être le candidat de la
droite et du centre
il va être le candidat de la droite et
du centre parce qu'il a derrière lui
deux parties et république et lui dei
parce qu'il a derrière lui le peuple de
la droite et du centre qui ont fait
sortir ce champion d'une primaire
réussie ça va être difficile c'est n'a
pas l'opinion avec la sphère qui ne
traverse avoir la droite mais pas
l'opinion est ce que c'est de nabeul je
pense qu'il a l'opinion parce que le
harcèlement médiatique qu'il vit que
nous vivons avec lui ces derniers jours
est en train de se retourner et je pense
que à travers ce combat cette lutte et
sa force c'est une nouvelle france aussi
qui est en train de naître une france
qui combat une certaine sphère
médiatico-politique ce qu'il a fait est
légal
peut paraître scandaleux c'est vrai il
ya un problème de décence mais qui est
partagé par l'ensemble des
parlementaires et je pense que c'est ces
contrecoups qui font naître au forceps
une nouvelle france une nouvelle figure
d lui et moi je suis fier d'être
porte-parole société civile de françois
fillon
je pense que c'est la société civile en
particulier porte aussi alors un mot
quand même sur cette affaire avant de
parler spécifiquement de la gauche
françois fillon a parlé de coup d'état
en particulier il a prononcé le mot coup
d'état alexandre emorine et tout le
monde une réaction quand même cette
affaire avant de
si on te ça monte l'image d'une caste
d'une espèce de voile à deux d'entre eux
soit qu'ils se croient au dessus des
lois qui trouve sa morale est normal
apparemment d'engager des membres de sa
famille dans des hautes sphères
politiques je suis désolé c'est pas du
tout ça rentre pas du tout dans le cadre
de la moralité de ce qu'attendent les
gens après est ce que françois fillon
sera toujours le candidat ou pas j'en
veux dire que ça c'est secondaire
ce qu'il y aura un candidat de droite
qui portera un programme ce sera le même
programme de classe sociale de casse de
la sécurité sociale et d'austérité donc
au final
certes c'est honteux mais c'est aussi
honteux que ce qui se passe pour les
assistants parlementaires du front
national au parlement européen tout ça
fait partie d'une même d'un même
ensemble de gens qui se penche au dessus
au dessus des autres et d'une caste qui
ne raisonnent que quand tu reçois car
vous n en a pas beaucoup entendue
finalement le reste de la classe
politique alors envie de dire il n'ya
peut-être pas besoin pour vous la faire
se suffit à elle même
moi j'ai tendance à à ne pas à ne pas
amplifier l'acharnement médiatique sur
les personnes quel que soit ce qu'elles
ont fait cependant dans cette affaire
précisément il ya l'esprit et à la
lettre
moi j'étais vendredi avec des jeunes
dans un lycée et parmi les questions
qu'ils ont posées ils m'ont posé la
question est ce que quelqu'un qui est
poursuivi par la justice doit se
présenter
c'est quelque chose qui parle à un autre
jeunesse et je crois que c'est quand
même important que un élu ou en tout cas
un candidat s'il a quelque chose à se
reprocher ou qu'on lui reproche même si
on est dans un pays de droit il ya la
présomption d'innocence
il faut pas négliger quand même cet
aspect
la classe politique était beaucoup
crédibiliser et cette affaire amplifie
le mouvement et je crois que c'est parce
qu'il est souhaitable en ce moment
entrepris je pars commentaire à faire
vous juger de manière à ne commente pas
de sifflets assemble commentaire à faire
c'est une affaire entre françois fillon
et sa conscience
françois fillon et la justice
éventuellement il n'est pas saisi
aujourd'hui vous verra bien le
déroulement de le faire vous savez nous
sommes avec les maillols bakouma une
démarche où nous proposons un projet d
essayons de rassembler les français
notre relève n'est pas allé dire du mal
de tel ou tel des candidats autour de
nous
chacun porte aujourd'hui son projet pour
l'île longtemps moi j'entends le porter
avec beaucoup de détermination et à ne
pas commenter les affaires actuellement
même si je vois le désarroi qui existe
dans ce pays parce que on est amené à
faire des commentaires d'une affaire
judiciaire et je vous suis tout à fait
c'est normalement une chose que l'on ne
serait pas fermé vue finalement le point
politique que ça on est bien obligé de
celles qu'on était à l'élection
présidentielle c'est donc je rappelle
que ce qui fait légale qu'un tiers des
députés lui fait un tiers des sénateurs
aussi que c'est un usage de la
république française et moi il ya deux
choses il ya le fait de salariés un
membre de sa famille il y aura la
question de savoir si l'emploi est
réelle ou pas il ya parraine deux points
et ont prévu une grande difficulté comme
vous savez j'ai des responsabilités
industriel dans un grand groupe français
on a une réelle difficulté qu'il n'y a
pas de fiche de poste pour un assistant
parlementaire à ce qui complique tout
nos commentaires ce qui fait que le
travail aussi de l' enquête n'est pas
simple on sait qu'il ya un travail
mettant le travail et à décrire et je
pense qu'il faut continuer
voilà moi je vous prends pas bien car
j'ai une question à vous poser avant
qu'on passe aussi à la gauche mais si
françois fillon devait se retirer vous
qu'il suivait depuis le début vous
suivent riez un autre candidat de droite
à la présidentielle c'est ça pour est
emblématique de ce qui se passe il votre
réponse moi je pense que voilà on a
commencé certains dans notre parti a
parlé d'un plan b et je pense que c'est
pas le faire par exemple sénateurs de
pousser bien je sais bien
absolument et je pense que ce plan b
serait une catastrophe parce que c'est
pas le plan b après ac le plan b des
barreaux je pense qu'on a voulu une
primaire de la droite et du centre elle
a beaucoup mobilisé plus que celle de la
gauche on ne s'y attendait pas champion
et sorties inattendues et le corps se
défend de ses champions inattendu je
pense que c'est la même chose d'ailleurs
pour benoît hamon 1
donc je pense qu'il faut écouter le
peuple
parce que le peuple est en colère
aujourd'hui ceux qui ont voté à la
primaire ceux qui n'ont pas voté
on est en train de vivre une évolution
de notre démocratie les prêts vers les
primaires n'était pas prévu par la
constitution mais elles existent donc
moi je reste derrière françois fillon
mais je serai fidèle à mon parties de
l'essieu
on passe à la gauche françois fillon
vainqueur surprise on va dire de la
primaire de droite benoît hamon
vainqueur aussi surprise la primaire de
gauche en souvient que certains
pronostiquaient françois patriat nous
racontait les coulisses d'un débat
précédent monastique et d'autres
vainqueurs que benoît hamon naïvement
kerra bouziane est ce que benoît hamon
candidat du ps c'est une chance de
gagner l'élection présidentielle est ce
que de votre point de vue il doit aller
parler à jean luc mélenchon jean luc
mélenchon qui va tenir un meeting
important aujourd'hui et benoît hamon en
ce moment même qui en gros fait son
discours d'investiture pour le ps vous
voulez quoi vous que benoît hamon parle
à jean luc mélenchon que benoît hamon
parle à emmanuel macron représenté ici
par françois patriat vous voulez quoi
maintenant tout seul et gagnera pas bien
sûr et justement la gauche est condamnée
si elle veut si elle veut gagner cette
élection
elle est condamnée à s'unir et
d'ailleurs gagné que lorsqu'elle a été
uni bien sûr il a annoncé tout de suite
après sa désignation qu'il allait parler
à la fois à jean luc mélenchon mais
aussi
radicaux mais il n'a pas du tout parlé
de l'est le centre et centre droit du ps
il n'a pas du tout parlé aux supporters
de manuel valls et vincent peillon par
exemple alors les laissons les choses se
faire mais c'est un choix
ça veut dire c'est un cap à gauche est
ce que ça veut dire que c'est un coup de
barre à gauche au ps c'est un coup de
barre à gauche oui c'est un coup de
barre à gauche puisque on au nom
prédisaient un échec de cette primaire
et bien sûr les chèques notamment de
l'ale dit gauche du parti socialiste
oui c'était c'est c'est un désir de
gauche que l'on vit aujourd'hui sachant
qu'en cas sinon vous n'avez pas été
tendre avec benoît hamon pendant la
primaire
bon vous le soutenir arnaud montebourg
donc mais c'est l'exercice qui le veut
donc moi je ne suis pas pour ce genre de
de pratiques d'attaquer mais bon c'est
le jeu ça c'est fait mais il s'est
rallié tout de suite après lui parce que
ce qui est important je crois c'est
qu'est ce qui nous rassemble est ce que
ce qui nous rassemble est plus important
de ce qui nous divise et je crois que
c'est à partir de là que l'on peut
construire avec mélenchon mais avec
l'ensemble de ceux qui se retrouvent
dans les valeurs de gauche avec sandrine
on suivait à dijon cette soirée de la
primaire ps nous en reportage il y avait
des gens de votre parti qui était tout
près des gens de du ps moi je me
souviens sera sauf que ce qu'ils nous
disaient en marge de cette soirée c'est
mais s'ils croient qu'on va négocier il
se trompe on n'a aucune raison négocier
avec le ps nous suivait la lettre on ne
va pas être là pour négocier des
ralliements des choses comme ça contre
10,2 contre des circonscriptions ça
c'est sûr nous ce qu'on veut c'est la
clarté et un moment benoît hamon il va
devoir trancher aussi la balle est dans
son camp
on a l'impression quand même que au
moment de la primaire pour gagner cette
primaire il fallait prendre nos
positions par contre je pense que pour
sauver le parti socialiste il va devoir
les abandonner
s'il veut concilier ce que vous disiez
tout à l'heure avec manuel valls une ré
mes conneries et c'est maintenant vous
êtes moins position de force quand même
vous depuis de benoît hamon et le
candidat du ps on a vu jean luc
mélenchon descendre dans les sondages et
les sondages va vous avez eu tout un
battage médiatique quand même pendant
tout le mois de janvier on n'a parlé que
de la primaire du parti socialiste
donc au bout d'un moment voilà les
questions dynamique ça va ça revient un
précédent c'est françois fillon quand il
a été nommé à la fin de la primaire tout
le monde le voyait gagnant
30% aujourd'hui il est à maximum 20 et
on voit que tout peut changer en trois
mois donc la question n'est pas là par
contre sur la question de l'union je
reviens savez sur des questions de
programme nous on est prêts à discuter
avec tout le monde ya aucun problème par
contre benoît hamon il a du chemin à
faire pour venir pour venir vient de
jean luc mélenchon ils agissent matin
c'était nouveau quand même le dialogue
est possible à condition que benoît
hamon rompent avec l'ancien monde et
bien sûr mais c'est quand même la base
c'est jeux anciens monde est un concept
assez abbas et c'est les gens qui ont
gouverné pendant des années qui ont mis
la situation dont la qui ont mis la
france de la situation dans laquelle
elle aujourd'hui
comment vous voulez abroger la loi elle
conneries quand vous avez dit rien mais
le briquet députés ou manuel valls qui
serait députés est donc soutenu par
benoît hamon ça c'est pas possible et
après on a aussi un peu
bah oui mais ça sert à ça mais c'est
aussi des questions sont mais celui-ci
des questions fonds dont va pas
s'arranger sur un fait pour des postes
vous avez aussi nous si vous voulez on a
cru un moment à l'exemple à l'exemple
grec en grèce vous aviez alexis tsipras
ce nom on y croyait
simplement il n'a rien pu faire parce
qu'il a fait le choix de ne pas rompre
avec les traités européens
donc toutes les politiques sociales qui
peuvent être éventuellement prônée par
benoît hamon il fait le choix de rester
dans le cadre des traités européens dont
il ne pourra pas les mettre en place
ça c'est une différence de fond nous on
est cohérent on choisira de rompre pour
mettre en place la plus bêtement vous
parlez de discuter mais moi je suis un
peu naïf mais ça fait deux patrons quand
même temps est ce que ça voudrait dire
qu'un candidat se retirerait pas ce que
vous nous dites discuter mais au final
si vous discutez que vous mettez
ensemble ça veut dire benoît monde
pourrait ne pas être le candidat à la
présidentielle et laisser jean luc
mélenchon mais la question avec alain
lacroix jean luc mélenchon quand on
parle de 10 à 6 c'est quand même la
question c'est une élection
présidentielle c'est une période bien
sûr mais c'est aux français de trancher
ensuite il s'est pas à telle ou telle
personne de retirer sa part françois
patriat quatre ans et qui moquaient
union je me passais sous contrat un
petit peu désespéré j'entends mais des
amis autour de cette table ici parce que
moi j'ai deux lits station pour personne
nous sommes plutôt dans la bienveillance
tout ça fait cuisine si la boutique ou
parle de boutiques haut de de ralliement
de par aliments d'anathème on va couper
la tête des cd des parlementaires qui
aurait soutenu et cetera manuel valls
non moi je veux pas parler des autres
couples je veux parler mais j'ai entendu
j'ai entendu pas revenir dessus mais
j'ai entendu
votre leader dire qu'il fallait que
benoît hamon ne retire l'investiture aux
parlementaires de la droite de la droite
du parti socialiste parce qu'il devait
tout vu donc c'est bien quand même c'est
la fed et est très bien mais ça c'est
alors le rassemblent nous le problème
avec emmanuel macron nous ne voulons pas
rassembler des partis ou des appareils
nous voulons rassembler les français
râlent sur le fond c'est qu'il soit
aujourd'hui de gauche et de droite mais
qui pense à une seule chose
réformer ce pays créé une société du
travail crée aujourd'hui de l'égalité de
la protection et pour ce faire vous
demandons aujourd'hui à ces gens
d'adhérer individuellement à une
démarche commune qui est une démarche de
progressisme et qui est la seule qui
permet aujourd'hui de sortir leur dire
si chacun reste dans son camp dans son
camp du bien à la droite orléaniste
bonapartiste à l'extrême droite ou à la
gauche de la gauche on n'avancera pas
ensuite oui dans cette démarche
aujourd'hui dans cette démarche
aujourd'hui nous avons dit qu'est ce que
nous voulons libérer et protéger libérer
les forces vives de ce pays parce que
nous pensons que l'associé du travail
est la seule société qui permettent de
développer notre pays
le travail est ensuite protéger mieux
parce que je pense que par rapport aux
autres candidats
emmanuel macron n'est pas celui qui voit
le monde dans un rétroviseur ils voient
le monde tel qu'il est aujourd'hui avec
des méthodes et des réformes pour demain
alors que les autres il voit toujours
dans leur méthode de négociation et
autres le monde tel qu'il a été avec les
méthodes d'hier
c'est ce qui changera non j'ai une
question à vous poser et qui qui peut
concerner tout le monde quand même un
centre quelque chose qui réunirait là
gauche et la droite
est-ce que ça peut exister dans dix ans
vous allez me dire que j'ai pas compris
mais ça c'est la question est ce qu'un
centre peut exister dans un système
français où il ya que le scrutin
majoritaire où il n'ya pas de
proportionnelle ou un centre peut pas
exister
électoralement et ce qui est un débouché
électoral à chaque fois la réponse a
avancé c'est quand la droite et la
gauche opposé un peu les angles
parce qu'elle était en grande difficulté
pour sauver la vie d'un bel exemple on a
cité hier à lyon liv et j'ai l'idée g
simone veil
la droite n'est pas tout fait pour lui
et qui survivent et j'ai la gauche c'est
quand la droite et la gauche s'étant les
gens progressiste
droite et de gauche se sont retrouvés
qu'ils ont fait avancer ce sujet de lits
vg le jour où il a fallu sauver la
france après la guerre de 40 le jour qui
le conseil national de la résistance 1
qui a fait les bases de ce contrat que
tout le monde défend aujourd'hui il a
été fait par la droite et par la gauche
donc il s'agit la gauche doit exister
encore la droite doit exister encore nés
les gens de droite et de gauche doit
pouvoir se retrouver pour travailler
pourquoi
non pas pour leurs boutiques non pas
pour leur parti mais pour le bien commun
de ce pays qui a besoin de se redresser
dans un monde difficile avec ce qu'on
voit aux états unis avec le terrorisme
aujourd'hui dans besoin de rassemblement
et pas de divisions de boutiques et de
partis dont les français n'ont plus que
faire alors rassemblement de droite et
de la gauche cela devienne cardo d'abord
on sait qu'il ya quand même des gens
pardonnez moi juste pour relancer qu'il
ya des gens qui supportaient alain juppé
par exemple chez les jeunes qui sont
rejoindre emmanuel macron oui mais
forcément moi je comprends très bien
j'écoute françois patriat et ses
formules à midi exactement ce que
françois fillon a dit pendant que la
primaire de la droite
j'ai écouté emmanuel macron hier et
finalement c'est c'est une vision de la
droite la réforme et le travail ont
changé la france d'aujourd'hui
la seule chose c'est que nous la droite
on a présenté un projet concret détaillé
chiffrés et que j'écoutais
emmanuel mannoury hier on n'est encore
sûr je vous ai écoutés s'est parlé on et
j'écoutais emmanuel macron hier bon
c'était on est encore sur une vision
très généraliste des envolées lyriques
qui se veulent ni de droite ni de gauche
mais qui sont vraiment très proche de ce
qu'il a pu faire comme ministre de la
hollande y est surtout on ne voit pas
derrière comment on va arriver dans
l'état terrible de la france
d'aujourd'hui vous avez vu les taux
d'intérêts roman le pétrole augmente on
a eu pendant les cinq années de françois
hollande un alignement des planètes dont
on n'a pas profité
maintenant la situation devient de plus
en plus critique et moi j'aime beaucoup
et qui fait emmanuel macron qu'un
personnage romanesque à la française
talentueux qui fait briller les yeux je
le reconnais tout à fait je ne vois pas
ce qu'on va faire de précis et de
concret car benoît josiane des dégâts
des parlementaires socialistes qui
commencent à rejoindre hull macron on
avait prévu un d un départ massif ça
n'est vraiment pas le cas ils doivent
être une discussion ce travail justement
je voudrais revenir
on ne cherche pas à sauver un parti où
des partis on cherche aussi à construire
un projet pour la france
il faut pas nous enfermer dans ces
petites querelles de chacun sa chapelle
non c'est pas le sais pas en tout cas
c'est pas là la candidature de benoît
hamon
et quand ils s'adressent quand il fait
son projet il s'adresse aux français
alors moi je veux bien j'apprends que
macro se prépare depuis deux ans quelle
loyauté
il nous a fait faire quand même passer
des lois que très peu de parents
devaient heureusement donc donc il y
avait déjà peut-être une idée qui est
qui qui germait la france qu'on peut
partager chaque nom mais on a le droit
c'est pas un reproche c'est juste pour
dire quand même il n'a fait pas de
passer des lois au 49 3 d'ailleurs la
loi travail s'il a regretté que ce soit
pas lui qu'il qu'il les eut je la
soutiens j'avais pas la manger mais
c'est par le mais c'est une
mais c'est toujours c'est tout moi je
l'aurais pas voter et je suis pour
qu'elles soient abrogées parce que
justement parlé de libérer et de
protéger comment on peut protéger un
salarié aujourd'hui avec la loi y
compris et l'inversement de la
hiérarchie des normes
donc voila c est ce qu est la lousiane
est-ce que et est ce que le ps est ce
que le découpage des partis politiques
français historique n'est pas mort est
ce que on se dirige pas vous parliez
tout à l'heure de la grèce s'aide alexis
tsipras ce est-ce que sur le mode de la
recomposition des partis politiques en
europe actuellement particulier à gauche
le ps a pas vocation s'il est mené par
benoît hamon à se rapprocher d'une
partie plus à gauche et et qu'un autre
pôle de centre centre gauche peut-être
avec du centre droit se fasse autour d'
emmanuel macron et est-ce que c'est fini
le parti socialiste d'epinay le grand
rassemblement en tout cas aujourd'hui ça
n'est pas à l'ordre du jour mais rien
n'est interdit pour évoluer
mais pour le moment le parti socialiste
existe il a un candidat qui défend son
projet le cycle d'epinay terminer le
cycle de l'union de la gauche telle
qu'elle a été conçue par françois
mitterrand avec des synthèses autour
d'un homme fort qui pouvait le même la
gérer et termine aujourd'hui la ligne
d'à gauche telle qu'elle a vécu avec
françois mitterrand
j'ai participé moi je venais à l'époque
déjà de l'époque des réformistes et ce
qui me peine aujourd'hui c'est de voir
que dans la gauche
moi j'ai toujours travaillé depuis 40
ans et je reste un homme de gauche
aujourd'hui si toujours les forces
conservatrices qui l'ont emporté une
nouvelle fois avec cette primaire les
réformistes ont été encore mis en
minorité je le regrette pour ce pays
pas pour moi je n'attends rien de la
politique pour le futur j'essaie de
construire dans ce pays des forces et
qui pourront demain leurs efforts mais
voilà donc le 6 il a été maintenu
ensuite avec lionel jospin jeu ce pâté à
nos forces mais depuis jeudi
aujourd'hui avec avec les présidents qui
sont succédé cette union de la gauche
aujourd'hui elle est en brèche ya une
gauche de la gauche
qu'on le veuille ou non il ya deux
gauches irréconciliables et ceux de
gauche aujourd'hui je le crois je le
pense
quand j'entends les amis de jean luc
mélenchon mais quand j'entends les amis
de manuel valls je suis aujourd'hui
qu'ils ne peuvent plus travailler
ensemble donc il faut trouver un nouveau
modus aujourd'hui pour gérer ce pays et
ce pays va se faire avec des
bush et avec des gens de droite qui vont
trouver ensemble alors quand j'entends
dire pas le credo ya pas de programme
n'y a pas d'idée emmanuel mac ont encore
évoqué hier 37 37 propositions concrètes
touchant l'agriculture la défense
l'école la santé la série culte des
journées non cela gâche au furet
convaincre et la brillanne soit ya des
gens qui râlent ces gens bien répondre
aux questions qui me sont posées
emmanuel macron de poser le diagnostic
il y a deux ans ils avaient dit que sans
doute françois hollande serait pas dans
la possibilité de se représenter et que
nous ne pouvions pas ne pas réfléchir à
l'époque à une façon de faire de la
politique autrement
c'est pour ça que je trie suis très fier
d'avoir été le seul parlementaire
présent amiens côtés d'emmanuel matheron
et faire d'un mouvement qui était 0 le 6
avril
aujourd'hui quinze cent cinquante mille
adhérents dont hier 15000 était présent
à lyon ça prouve qu'il ya une non
seulement qu'il y à un parti qui lie à
un mouvement qu'il y a un devoir ce
qu'il y a une idée pour la france une
idée pour la france et qu'il y en ait
ensuite rabelais moutonne le genre à qui
veut l'entendre
alessandrini laquelle on va parler dans
des vacances la matriarche rachel vous
plaît de la présidente et les manoeuvres
d'appareil et d'avancer franchement
alexandre et mangane irréconciliables et
gauche tels que vient de dire françois
patriat de votre point de vue
irréconciliables et ça veut dire que
jean luc mélenchon doit tracer sa route
sur son programme dans cette campagne de
toute façon on a un programme
il est clair il est il a été visiblement
tendu je l'avais programme de dire si je
ne disais pas gmt moi je la justice
viendrait on était juste ici il fait 160
160 pages on a un très bien les
trentaine de livres et thématiques qui
comptent chacun plus de 100 kg bref on
est là dessus interrogées les français
ce programme des mâles macron je pense
qu'ils voudront y en a pas je crois que
les français seront interrogés fin avril
à l'aller ce moment là mais en tout cas
c'est sûr que les deux gauches
irréconciliables
alors c'est le grand t en cadet t on
peut les pros manuel valls mais nous on
n'a rien à voir avec la politique qui a
été menée depuis cinq ans ça c'est ça
c'est une réalité mais on va pas se
rassembler avec des gens qui soutiennent
que je pense à manuel valls pense à
mirabel conneries ce qui a été fait
depuis cinq ans ou comme monsieur macro
qui que monsieur macron on a tous
l'impression qu'on le découvre un petit
peu en ce moment mais monsieur mation
totalement les réformes qu'il a portée
je vais parler
s'il vous plaît messieurs macro il a
travaillé pour nicolas sarkozy en 2010
il a été ministre de françois hollande
ensuite donc c'est quand même pas un
perdreau de l'année non plus c'est
quelqu'un qui vient ici qui se
présentent ici présents mais ça prouve
surtout qu'il ya aujourd'hui pour
terminer le travail
ça prouve qu'il est aujourd'hui pour
terminer le travail parce que j'avais
probablement pas pu assez loin selon lui
mais on voit que sa politique est l'ami
clairement la france
dans la situation dans laquelle elle est
emmanuel macron il veut pérenniser le
cic donc les crédits d'impôt
compétitivité emploi
bien sûr oui mais c'est quelque chose
alors on peut prendre les chiffres on va
prendre les chiffres très clairs sur la
bourgogne le cic en bourgogne c'était
1,2 milliard d'euros qui ont été donnés
à certaines grandes entreprises
ces mêmes entreprises dans le même temps
aux licenciés 6000 personnes ça veut
dire que deux cent mille euros était
payée par tous par nous partout grâce à
120 jours je meurs c'est grâce aussi non
sans manier le chômeur devenu en france
s'ils sont réels et c'est la réalité
parce qu'ils sont l'un des gourous
comporte beaucoup pendant que vous
discutez de cic au caire à brienne et
fabien cardon vous le voulez réagir
il nous reste trois minutes d'émission
je voudrais juste dire un mot concernant
que vous aviez parlé de qui va désigner
qui il faut pas oublier que benoît hamon
était quand même désigné par à plus d'un
million deux cent mille personnes
alors on peut compter au lycée mais j'ai
fini pas c'est une légitimité
bien sûr si je voulais dire à jouer sur
la fiction des partis parce que je pense
que c'est vraiment important pour
l'évolution de la société française
et si j'ai l'honneur et le plaisir
d'être sur ce plateau c'est parce que
françois fillon veut essayer de faire
évoluer la politique française à travers
des gens de la société civile à nous
avons été nombreux à le rejoindre il
nous a fait aussi l'honneur à une
vingtaine d'entre nous d'être
porte-parole nationaux nous avons une
autre vision de la société nous ne
sommes pas des grands élus nous
connaissons le concret et difficulté ce
qu'on voit à la télé excusez moi c'est
quand même les grands élus de la droite
c'est pas on voit pas de rupture avec le
monde politique habituelle dans la
campagne de françois fillon jeudi dans
l'est dans les meetings de la primaire
nous nous avons fait nous les porte
parole national des meetings seul pour
porter son projet parce que finalement
ne me rends pas de se bourrer les
français aujourd'hui dans les médias de
la campagne de françois que le du projet
je vous parle du projet s'ils sont venus
si nombreux voter à la primaire c'est
parce qu'ils ont vu des gens
des gens qui connaissent les problèmes
concrets parce que ce qu'a dit hier
emmanuel macron pour les agriculteurs il
a dit je veux rendre aux paysans leur
fierté d'être en usant du jeune homme de
15 ans a laissé dois pas me battre je ne
dis pas le mensonge est légalement c'est
ce qu'il a dit non ce n'est pas ça dit
je sais que je suis hors vivent de leurs
produits et haddad aussi vous allez
laisser finir ma phrase c'était la
deuxième partie de la phrase fiers de
leur métier et vivent de leurs produits
mais il n'explique pas comment et c'est
une question complexe
donc je pense que maintenant mais la vie
politique s'appuie sur les réseaux
sociaux
d'ailleurs la campagne convient y
extrêmement porté par les réseaux
sociaux par des gens de la société
civile qui viennent appuyer les
candidats politiques et c'est vrai que
ça va amener une inflexion de cette
élection est une inflexion des projets
et ce qui est important c'est le projet
et c'est le projet concret et les
français décideront là dessus il nous
reste une ligne 30 d'émission on n'a pas
parlé d'un parti qui n'est pas avec nous
aujourd'hui parce qu'ils en sa campagne
à lyon c'est le front national dans tous
les sondages actuellement le deuxième
tour le front national il est battu
systématiquement
est-ce que très vite en quelques mots de
votre point de vue ça signifie que ce
sera comme ça ou pas du tout on sait que
jean luc mélenchon parle profond
nationale les réseaux france yves dans
une opposition contre le front national
louis de toute façon son projet c'est
pas un projet de futur pour les gens
c'est un projet d'exclusion des fusions
communautaire mais c'est le front
national comme le disent certains médias
étrangers compte tenu de ce qui se passe
en ce moment dans la vie politique
française ce qui est très compliqué peut
être en position de gagner l'élection
présidentielle
non nous parce que je savais les déçus
les gens qui sont en colère ils vont
passer ils vont pas au front national
ils vont à l'abstention principalement
au four nations et non ils vont dans
l'abstention gillaizeau recommandé pas
d'accord est ce que je peux et termine
mais il reste second ils sont dans
l'abstention et c'est pour ça qu'il faut
leur proposer des projets pour leur dire
ne les laissez pas s'occuper des choses
à votre place donc c'est pour ça qu'il
faut proposer un futur c'est ce que nous
propose le front national ce qui propose
si l'exclusion vous avez aussi avec
monsieur macro et de succion la
différence sociale nous propose un
universalisme humaniste un futur pour
les gens c'est ça c'est ça le principe
de l'émission est quasiment terminée je
vous étiez pas d'accord du tout sa façon
de parler au front national
il va falloir qu'on fasse beaucoup
d'autres versions
on vérifie les identités de l'émission à
terminer je vous remercie parce que vous
êtes en train de tricher de parler sur
ce générique merci à tous les quatre bon
dimanche et restez avec nous pour la
deuxième partie de dimanche en politique
dont l'invité sera ségolène royal invité
francis letellier
merci vont dimanche au revoir
[Musique]